It would take 60 hours or about two and a half days for the pool to fill. Great
work if you found this. This is the equation that we'll use to help us solve.
We can fill the pool in 10 hours, and we can drain one pool in 12 hours. We
know that when you subtract the 1 12th here since it takes longer to drain the
pool than it does to fill it. In other words this rate is it slower than this
rate? And this should make sense, since we know 1 12th is smaller than 1 10th.
So, the pool will fill up ever so slightly, and we can figure out the total
time that it takes to fill the pool, this is x. We start solving this equation
by multiplying through by the LCD 60x. The common factors of 10 and 12 are 2.
The other factor of 10 is 5, and the other factor of 12 is 6. We multiply these
factors together, which give us 60, and then we have to multiply by x, the
other factor in our denominators. We multiply by x since x is not a common
factor of 10 or 12. So 60x will be our LCD. This first term will reduce to 6x,
since 60 divided by 10 equals 6. The second term will reduce to 5x, since 60
divided by 12 equals 5. This leaves us with the right hand side of just 60.
Combining our like terms on the left, we'll have 1 x equals 60, so x equals 60
hours. The time it takes to fill the pool with the drain open.